Randy I think we need to have a talk no
time to talk the agricultural inspectors
about to drop by once we get certified
from him we can start selling like a
real farm have patience wife soon our
fortunes will change OOP that must be
him now
yes I'm with the state testing board is
this integrity farms names right there
on the side come on back
so with this festooned device I can
check not only the THC levels in your
product but also detect any impurities
and give you a final score based on
overall chemical makeup yeah that's good
now let me test the levels in your
organic house blend yep that's good
now what about the Tegrity jungle bud
let's test it out whoa yeah whoa yeah I
don't know what a gritty is but that is
some good
you